you did not turn that into a head but
it's the worst thing wear it please wear
that that puts it before this video
begins let me just plug Sookie that's
right
check out Sookie dot market because we
released why are you sad again our
collection why you saying but in black
very epic super nice cropped overalls
how comfy cute and angry sweater how
nice and most of all comfy augurs check
out Sookie market and let's get on with
video everything is awful that's what
we're reviewing today because I need you
guys to prepare for when I'm finally
going on a break to understand that
other things are bad too I'm gonna skip
the top ones just cuz they're so awful
it's not even funny I mean this one is a
classic a couple dividing up their
beanie baby collection in divorce court
1990 actual adult children everyone
that's what it looks like
he thought degeneracy was a new thing oh
no no man accused of exposing himself at
a public pool I never seen someone looks
so young yes so old so feminine yes so
masculine so pretty yes so ugly I am
truly yeah it looks like one of those
phase swapped or something what am i oh
my god then when I look at it ah best
friends who do plastic surgery together
stay together oh my god oh you can start
a support group for we stuff our faces
she looks so much better
oh no why did you do it why did you rip
your friend into this did a friend not
see what happened to you did you not
look at this and thought no I don't want
that to happen to my face maybe I
shouldn't join in on this I think a drew
this girl when I was for this because
faces look like PlayStation 1 graphic it
truly does my god maybe that's what
they're going for this is a gaming
conference it's finally a lot of women
at these events finally see whamon can
be gamer too I knew it oh god I saw this
stepped on a cricket at work came back
to clean it up and a parasite is
crawling out of its body
ah ha
ah this is making me physically pain
physical pain ah same thing will happen
if you step on me I've been a puppet all
along someone else has been pulling the
strings there has got to be a better way
to display children no I think that's
the only way this could be your child
you want child hanging from ceiling
getting not one but two corporate logos
tat on you come on if you're truly based
you get at least your whole body covered
with corporate logos so what's your
personality like I I'm a big fan of
Apple and Starbucks and that's my entire
personality but if there's only was a
way for me to tell people about this so
they would be no doubt about it
oh I know Lake tattoo how quirky help us
conserve paper use a hand towel we wash
these every week don't worry
Wow every week incredible they wash it
every week these people just solve any
environmental badness when the sign says
don't worry you should definitely worry
you should always worry that hits a huge
red flag that means they probably don't
even wash it every week I'll come on not
mine okay this is not theirs the
struggle the uneven tear the cat ill
what is oh it's the worst video I've
ever seen first they can't pull it then
the double tear oh and then there's a
pool inside of eight and then there's a
four chick art truly art oh you know
this dude doesn't even have my shoes
the girl is digging to China and this
old lady has the worst wig oh my god
America everyone the land of the free
how did you know it's you would say I
just know sometimes you just know that
is a great week I don't understand what
anyone anyone could ever say about
that's a great wig she's just doing what
makes her happy Felix how much dirt is
in public transport see
Oh God oh Jesus Christ no why god you're
in layers of fart that is that's fart
Adams exfoliating itself you're sitting
on a the hot water on my school
literally turns black L oh my god well I
hope you guys know this is why you're
not supposed to drink the hot water you
I know a lot of people when they cook
food a bunch of morons dum-dums what
they do is they put hot water in the
saucepan when they're gonna boil the
water cuz bigbrain hot water oh it goes
faster hot water is really bad okay it's
black don't use it you can wait a couple
seconds for the cold water which is
cleaner local wedding photographer the
more I look the funnier it is what
thank you local wedding photographers
very good God the world is all for
listening this really makes you see it
decided to open and clean my PlayStation
2 controller Oh Oh God not another
parasite someone at the office must be
losing weight oh my god stop it
Kanye's new shoe design that is not a
shoe you have got to be shooting me yes
I I made that joke wash all the foot
boys wear this though Bionicle face well
now I want them I'm already sold its
advanced Crocs first they laugh but then
they buy oh my god he literally stole
from Bionicle I can't believe it there's
many things I don't understand and these
shoes are one of them I understand what
they're going for I think I just hate
the design I hate it Little Caesars
employee making a pizza except with no
gloves and naked baby in her arms not to
mention the baby was crawling on the
floor as well both sad and awful thank
you I will not have the pizza do you
know what's the worst about babies the
germs they spread
I've been saying on this channel for a
long time in case you knew when I'm not
present well leader or whatever
I will ban all children because children
are literal germs spreading creatures
and no one likes it no one likes them
and I will pray I will prevent things
like this from happening
there will be no germs spread pizza with
baby poop on it it will not happen on my
roll this is from a 90s baseball video
game I've seen this where a Japanese
game designer had to make up a bunch of
American names sleeve Mac dicker tight
girl
onsen swimmy daryl aqui del D aqui del
these are great names ray Mex riff
Bobson Doug nut
Bobson Doug nut she was trying to avoid
jail by impersonating her 21 year old
daughter well you could have fooled me
what is this Ollie London Ollie London's
mom a great use of new vamps oh this is
a DIY Oh perfect I love this stuff
because it's so awful it's literally the
same thing it's the whole sub ready
what are you gonna make what kind of
quirky thing are you gonna put out of
this all right place your bets in the
comments what is his waffles you did not
turn that into a head the hipster thing
wear it please wear that I want to see
how it looks on head
can someone please make that that is
awful
yeah why don't you try it all on the
video and show everyone how stupid it
looks you coward huh
everything is truly helpful my therapist
captain crack is it's too much go into
to rape trials Bill Cosby goes
temporarily blind Weinstein suddenly did
you actually pull up with that tennis
balls at the end
Weinstein looks like he's about to throw
that prop walker away and go primal into
spontaneous dance up oh god that's so
funny you cannot be serious
you cannot be serious an australian moth
that flies it flies I am cringing oh I
want to make some sort of fire joke but
I can't I just want leave I want to go I
knew goblins were real they're goblins
they're walking around
they've just integrated sighs the
goblins are real I'm starting to
understand this while reading this sub
ready oh where have I heard this story
before the perfect woman huh Wow
I'm not addicted I'm just trying to look
perfect okay who was the MF that did the
surgery though right it takes two to
tango who did this
huh someone really wanted that 76 dollar
paycheck huh
Jesus Christ oh my god Ricky get go
hiding in my son's toys
stop it this person try to unlock your
phone I knew it I think I recognize him
from some sort of tragic news event I
swear I've seen it on the news I
actually got a headache I'm not even
joking this sub R it is too much for me
to bear Oh God I got a really bad
headache oh no I got a perservere we got
to do this together oh no sometimes the
lash gets in my eye then I blink and
suddenly it's gone but sometimes I
wonder if there's a space behind filled
with eyelashes thank you for that
wonderful image thank you so much for
sharing that
I truly appreciate it I baked some
strawberry cakes in cat shaped pants and
they look like this is so hard this is
truly torture I'm in pain oh I don't
remember this sound sounding like
imagine fanners snapping and the only
people surviving her people looking like
this damn it
would you guys like some wet yoga class
you will be completely soaked in harbor
liquid Oh
attendees must learn to fold / unfold
their pee-pee do not attend if you can't
hold your breath for 33 lunar seconds
what the [ __ ]
free tree bark snack provided Wow
what a steal there will be loud
screaming don't eat onion 48 hours
before imagine signing up for this that
sounds hilarious I kind of want to do it
for the mean oh my god
expectation versus reality yeah how did
it get like that I feel this is where
they dip their arms stop a pull up your
sleeves you're disgusting human you
don't deserve a human body you filthy
scum take back take it back take back
all of it stop clicking on it Felix
what is this why does this keep
happening stop doing this stop
hey stop it get some help stop it what
on God's earth is that that's not real
is it
that was a puppet but why would you make
that just take it back and burn it
please whose lip fillers look like a
tiny mouth within a lodge
ladies you look stupid all right
you may amongst your little girlie
friend group think that that looks good
because your other girlie friends have
it you look dumb
you look very dumb you look extremely
stupid no guy actually likes the way you
looks just so we clear
just stop it you're not funny I hate you
I hope you'll die burn in fire again
vote for me there will be none more
adesh okay forbidden Oreo Oh I will make
sure every last insect will be destroyed
I don't care about ethical consequences
I don't care about any of it I will make
sure it's happened we start with the
insects we then take the children that's
my plan
just let me know smash like if you are
on board I got a headache and I feel bad
now I hope you feel bad too
see you tomorrow I should have gone on
my break from that either thank you you
haven't been training on pixels we'll
get on it you're ranked PvP matches are
live don't call yourself a gamer unless
you're up here in PewDiePie's pics links
find the tears get Fame points make 19
year olds cry and unlock new arenas epic
oh did I mention there pics links
you're welcome
[Music]